welcome everyone I'd like to introduce
you today to our speaker Dan Harris dan
Harris is a correspondent for ABC News
an award-winning anchor for a Nightline
and co-anchor for the weekend edition of
Good Morning America he's also author of
two books the first it was 10 percent
happier how I tamed the voice inside my
head reduced stress without losing my
edge and found self-help that actually
works a true story and most recently his
book meditation for fidgety skeptics at
10 percent happier how to book denne is
also an entrepreneur and the founder of
the meditation app 10 percent happier
which you should all download
immediately dan called me a few years
ago to talk about the science of
compassion which is my field of research
and we've been friends ever since I have
noticed from spending time with him that
despite an incredibly busy schedule as a
writer a TV anchor up at all hours of
the night an entrepreneur and the father
of a toddler who keeps him up the rest
of the night and despite living in the
midst of stressful Manhattan despite all
these things there's a deep sense of
calm that you feel in Dan's presence dan
has a committed daily meditation
practice he embraced meditation when he
had a panic attack on live TV which I'm
sure he'll tell you about Dan has the
amazing ability to blend keen
intelligence and insight with humor
spontaneity and inner peace we often
think of success as something that can't
come without stress I would think that
especially on this campus this is an
idea that we often embrace but Dan shows
us that it can and that it's something
we all could learn a thing or two about
and I know I'm excited to learn from Dan
tonight so please help me to welcome Dan
Harris to Yale
okay
thanks everybody I take a special
pleasure of being invited to speak at
institutions that definitely would have
rejected my application I'm looking
around I can see there are people who
were old enough to appreciate the joke
I'm about to tell which is that a few
years ago I put out this book and which
is about meditation and and after that
my wife and I had our like up lucky year
later we had our first child and after
that I found myself up in the middle of
the night holding this screaming beast
one night and there was poop everywhere
and I had this thought which is the
title of my next book is gonna be
everything in my last book was [ __ ]
that's like only partially true I would
say if you had told me that you know 5 6
7 8 9 years ago that I was ever gonna
become what I am now which is a
traveling evangelist for meditation I
would have coughed my beer up through my
nose this was not my plan I was not in
any way interested in meditation but
funny things happen in all of our lives
and for me this whole thing started
because I had a panic attack on national
television on a little show we do at ABC
News called Good Morning America because
I'm a huge masochist I actually asked
our research department to find out
exactly how many people were watching
and they came back with the reassuring
number of 5.01 9 million so you know not
a big deal and since I'm a masochist I
actually brought you a clip of the panic
attack so you can see it for yourself
once you roll it this is Good Morning
America welcome to the most embarrassing
day of my life we're going to go now to
Dan Harris's at the news desk morning
Charlie and Diane thanks this is me 10
years ago and the reason this is the
most embarrassing day of my life is not
that it looks like I've been attacked by
a blow dryer and a can of hairspray no
it's that I am about to freak out on
national television health news now one
of the world's most commonly prescribed
medications may be providing a big bonus
researchers report people who take
cholesterol-lowering drugs
called statins for at least five years
may also lower their risk for cancer but
it's too early to prescribe statins
slowly for cancer production at this
point I realize I'm helpless
so I bail right in the middle that does
it for news we're gonna go back now to
Robin and Charlie all right thanks very
much Dan Harris at the news desk with
some of the headlines of the morning
when I go to Tony Perkins now he once
the fear subsided humiliation rushed in
I knew with rock-solid certainty that I
had just had a panic attack on national
television so let's say advance that's
don't have to stare at that I have
watched that clip thousands of times and
it sucks every time I get one of two
responses to it if you've ever had a
taste of panic then you know exactly
what you were looking at other people
who are blessed not to have ever had a
panic attack or anything in its vicinity
they will often say to me it didn't
didn't look that bad it really doesn't
make a difference because I know it was
happening for me and it it it was awful
and even more embarrassing than freaking
out on national television is actually
the back story in other words what
produced the panic attack I think at the
root of it is something that everybody
at Yale for sure shares which is
ambition I arrived at ABC News at the
tender young age of 28 years old this is
the picture they took of me on my first
day at work it's still on my ID despite
repeated pleas for them to change it a
friend of mine has joked that it looks
like if you take a wide shot here I
might be holding a balloon in this
picture so I was really young and really
really insecure about my lack of
experience and I was working with giants
in our industry people like Diane Sawyer
Peter Jennings Barbara Walters and my
way of coping with this you know lack of
experience and and my worries about my
lack of experience was to essentially to
become a workaholic I just threw myself
into the job I had this I had this
thought
Loup running through my head all the
time of you know what what how good was
my last story what's my next door gonna
be who's getting the story that I wanted
what's my relationship with the bosses
right now it's my relationship with the
anchors blah blah blah and I really
believe that any success that I was
achieving was directly correlated to the
intensity of the aforementioned thought
loop anxiety loop really I had a motto
that was bequeathed to me by my father
who's an academic physician up at a
school in Cambridge whose name we
shouldn't utter here he his motto is the
price of security is insecurity which is
a great thing to tell a kid but I really
I really embraced that that idea and it
became my way of operating at ABC News
and so shortly after I arrived at ABC
News there was this big event in the
news which was 9/11 and after 9/11
happened I raised my hand and
volunteered to go overseas to cover
whatever happened next and my boss I
have to say that I fright I didn't
really think much about the
psychological consequences of this and
my bosses accepted my offer and so a
couple weeks after 9/11 I found myself
in Afghanistan say [ __ ] him this is a
picture of me some nice young gentleman
from the Taliban a couple of weeks after
9/11 this is in southern Afghanistan
when the Taliban was still in charge and
it was my first experience in a warzone
and the truth is that I liked it that is
not to say that I like violence I don't
I didn't I didn't even play contact
sports when I was a kid but there's an
expression there's nothing more
thrilling than the bullet that misses
you and in my case the bullets all
missed and that wasn't unfortunately not
true for many of my friends but after
this first experience I was hooked and I
spent a lot of time in places like
Afghanistan Pakistan Israel the West
Bank Gaza I was in Iraq six
and when I came home from one long trip
in Iraq in the summer of 2003 I got
depressed although I didn't actually
know I was depressed I was experiencing
what I now know to be the signature
signs and symptoms I was having trouble
getting out of bed I felt like I had a
low-grade fever all the time and at this
point I did an incredibly dumb thing
which is I started to self-medicate with
recreational drugs including cocaine and
ecstasy this is when the room usually
gets a little quiet I hasten to add I
don't know if you've ever seen that
movie the wolf of Wall Street were there
pounding quaaludes every five minutes
that was not me my drug use was pretty
short-lived and intermittent and it was
definitely not when I was working and
absolutely not when I was on the air but
so after I had the panic attack I went
to a doctor who's an expert in panic and
he asked me a bunch of questions to try
to figure out what had gone wrong and
one of the questions he asked was do you
do drugs and I said yeah I do and he
leaned back in his chair and gave me one
of the I don't know if anybody here has
ever been to a shrink but he gave me one
of those shrinky looks that communicated
the following sentiment okay [ __ ]
mystery solved and he pointed out that
even though my drug use had my drug
career had been quite short it was
enough to artificially raise the level
of adrenaline in my brain and primed me
to have a panic attack so this was a
huge aha moment for me I realized
immediately that I had been a huge dummy
and I also realized I needed to do
something about it so I agreed to quit
doing drugs and because quitting doing
drugs isn't that easy I agreed to go see
this doctor once or twice a week
indefinitely this however is not a neat
and tidy story where I quit doing drugs
and start meditating and my life is a
non-stop parade of unicorns and rainbows
something else had to happen and it came
in the form of this guy whose picture I
want to show you but I can't date not
that guy that guy I'll get to the
the other picture in a moment this guy
is Peter Jennings for you guys who are
too young to remember him he was a
massive news anchor in the United States
an American icon really although he was
from Canada and he was my mentor at ABC
when I first got there he passed away
about ten years ago and he took me aside
one day and said you Dan Harris are
gonna start covering faith and
spirituality for ABC News and I was like
no I don't want to do that I was raised
in the People's Republic of
Massachusetts both my parents are
secular scientists I did have a bar
mitzvah that's the picture I was going
to show you I did have a bar mitzvah but
I did this this is an actual bar mitzvah
picture I did this only for the money so
there was no I was not spiritually
inclined and I tried to explain all of
this to Peter but he didn't carry he
said you're gonna do it anyway and it
turned out to be a great thing for me I
I after I got this beat I spent many
years in mosques and mega churches and
Mormon temples and I made all these
really great new friends and I saw how
ignorant I was about issues related to
faith and spirituality and I saw the
value of having a worldview that
transcends your own narrow interests
that being said none of what I
encountered spoke to me personally you
know I didn't you know join a church or
go kosher or anything like that none of
it really hit me and my viscera until
the year 2008 so many years after my
panic attack and many years after I
started covering faith and spirituality
one of my colleagues recommended that I
read a book by if you guys could advance
it to the next one that would be awesome
this guy thank you recommended I read a
book by this guy I don't know if you I
didn't know who he was you his name is
Eckhart Tolle uh some of you may have
heard of him he's a mega best-selling
self-help guru I had as I said I had not
heard of him but I started to do a
little research and he's immensely
popular with celebrities apparently
Oprah Winfrey has put copies of his
books in every
bedroom in every in every house she owns
and Paris Hilton was seen carrying a
copy of one of his books when she went
into jail to do time for DUI so I
thought like it sounded weird enough for
a story for ABC News so I ordered one of
his books and I started to read it and
my first impression was not positive I
thought it was pure distilled [ __ ]
it was filled with all this pseudo
scientific language about vibrational
fields and all these grandiose claims
about how this book will produce for you
the reader a spiritual awakening
whatever that means and then he claims
that after his own spiritual awakening
he lived on park benches in a state of
bliss in the City of London for two
years I think I think they have winter
in London so I was like confused and I I
didn't believe any of it and I don't
know why but I kept reading and I'm glad
I did because he started to unfurl at
the further I read into his book a
really fascinating thesis about the
human condition tollis argument is that
we all have a voice in our heads there
we go there we go thank you I'll just
let you do all the investment his
argument will have a voice in our heads
by which he's not referring to
schizophrenia or hearing voices he's
talking about your intern aerator the
voice that chases you out of bed in the
morning and is yammering at you all day
long as you constantly wanting stuff or
not wanting stuff comparing yourself to
people judging other people judging
yourself thinking about the past or
thinking about the future to the
detriment of whatever's happening right
now
I have a friend who jokes that when he
when he considers the voice in his head
he feels like he's been hijacked by the
most boring person alive which just says
the same [ __ ] over and over most of it
negative all of it self referential and
tollis argument is when you're unaware
of this nonstop conversation you are
having with yourself it owns you it
Yanks you around this is why you find
yourself with your hand in the fridge
when you're not really hungry or you're
losing your temper when it doesn't make
any sense
or you're checking your email in the
middle of a conversation with another
homo sapien and and you know I read all
of this and hey this was another huge
aha moment for me because first of all I
realized well this is just intuitively
true second I realized that this thesis
about the human condition is what
produced though it was the voice in the
head that produced the most embarrassing
moment of my life it's why I went off to
war zones without thinking about the
consequences came home got depressed was
insufficiently self-aware to know it and
then I blindly self-medicated and it all
just you know blew up in my face suffice
it to say it was a little embarrassing
to be reading a book like can you
advance that one more it was a little
embarrassing to be reading a book by
this person and thinking he gets me but
even worse than the bruise to my ego was
the fact that I couldn't find any
actionable practical advice in his books
for dealing with the voice in the head
so I actually went to the delight of my
colleague who had recommended I read one
of his books I went to Toronto and
interviewed Eckhart Tolle and the first
thing I did was ask him you know what do
you do about the voice in the head and
he took a beat and said take one
conscious breath and the voice in my
head was like what the hell does that
mean and I asked him again and again you
know what seriously
what do you do about this I you you got
me this is a really interesting
observation what do you do but and he
seemed unwilling or unable to say
anything that made any sense to me and
then things got even weirder at one
point when I asked him whether he ever
gets into a bad mood we have video of
that don't you ever get annoyed
irritated sad anything negative no I
accept what is and that's why life has
become so simple
well somebody cut you off and they're in
your car it's fine it's like a sudden
gust of wind
I don't personalize a gust of wind
all and so it's simply what is and
you're able to enjoy every moment even
if I start asking you a ton of annoying
questions yes that would be fine so it's
really don't at me hahaha very
frustrating man I said this in the book
and my first book it was like he had
pointed out that my hair was on fire and
then just would not give me a fire
extinguisher and I really didn't know
what to do at this point because I was
very intrigued by his theory about the
way we are and so I did it what in
hindsight was a mistake I made a mistake
I spent a lot of time investigating the
self-help world which is filled with
people who will tell you that you can
solve all of your problems through the
power of positive thinking which is not
gonna happen
I can get on my high horse about this in
the Q&A if anybody wants but in the
interest of moving things along what
happened next was I came home from work
one night and my then fiancee and now
baby mama of Bianco who's here today
came at me with a gift she said you know
I've been hearing you talk about Eckhart
Tolle and the voice in the head and blah
blah blah and this is her talking she's
like it reminded me made me realize her
reminded me of a book that I read many
years ago and she hands me the book or a
couple books by this guy your good whose
name is dr. mark Epstein he's a
psychiatrist who lives and works in New
York City and he's been writing books
beautiful books for many years about the
overlap between psychology and Buddhism
and so I started to read one of his
books that night and I had another
moment was I realized that everything
that made any sense in that cart all his
books seemed to have been lifted largely
without attribution from somebody known
as the Buddha that was standing the fact
that I was ostensibly a religion
reporter actually knew nothing about the
Buddha other than I think I have a
picture of the guy I knew nothing about
him other than the fact that when I was
a 15 year old punk kid I actually stole
a Buddha statue from a local gardening
store in Newton Massachusetts and put it
in my bed
because I thought it would you know help
me with the ladies
just as a this is a bit of a digression
which but it didn't anyway back on story
I didn't know anything about the Buddha
but as it turns out 2600 years before
Eckhart Tolle started cashing his
royalty checks it was this guy
heretofore known to me as a lawn
ornament who was talking about the voice
in the head he had a different term for
it he called it the monkey mind I gotta
bring you to all my talks I don't have
to press a clicker again he called it
the monkey mind according to the Buddha
were like all like furry little animals
just hurling ourselves through a forest
of urges and impulses and desires
constantly latching on to things that
will not last in a universe that's
characterized by impermanence and
hurling ourselves from one hit of
pleasant experience one movie one a plus
on a paper one latte to the next and yet
never fully satisfied as my meditation
teacher likes to ask people how many
parties have you been - how many
vacations have you had how many great
meals have you enjoyed and are you done
of course not
we are insatiable and in this way the
pursuit of happiness that's in trying to
in our founding documents can become the
source of our unhappiness and unlike
Eckhart Tolle the Buddha actually had
practical advice for dealing with the
voice in the head my problem was what he
was recommending struck me as repellant
I think you know the punchline he was
recommending meditation I thought it
meditation was for people like this who
live in a yurt and are really into
aromatherapy and Tori Amos and Enya and
we're finger cymbals and used the word
namaste without any irony as it turns
out I was not
sadly entirely wrong about that but I
started to sniff around and I found that
there had been an explosion of
scientific research some of the key
studies in fact done right here at Yale
scientific research into what meditation
does
in your brain and in the rest of your
body and the results are really
intriguing I want to say I'll go into
the results briefly but before I do that
I want to say the people in my position
sometimes overhype this scientific
research it's a it's important to know
that the research is really in its early
stages but I think I think what we can
safely say is that it strongly suggests
that short daily doses of meditation can
produce a long list of tantalizing
health benefits like lowering the levels
of stress hormones in your brain
lowering your blood pressure boosting
your immune system here's where the
evidence is the strongest it's really
good for depression and anxiety also
ADHD age-related cognitive decline and
finally it's been shown to help with
things that are kind of surprising like
psoriasis and IBS both of which have
stress components and where things get
really sort of sci-fi is when we start
talking about the neuroscience in recent
years this is a real picture in recent
years neuro scientists have been peering
into the brains of meditators and what
they find and this is a little glib but
close enough what they find is when you
meditate you're in effect performing a
kind of neuro surgery on yourself you
are rewiring your brain and it's not
just people who wear robes there was a
study done sorry I have to say this word
at Harvard in 2010 I think we have some
imagery from the study they took people
who had never meditated before so
civilians people like us and they
scanned their brains put them in an MRI
fMRI and got a baseline look at what
their brains look like and then they had
these people do eight weeks of a little
bit of meditation every day and at the
end of the eight weeks they scan their
brains again and what they found was
that in the area of the brain associated
with self-awareness and with compassion
the gray matter literally grew and in
the area the brain associated with
stress the gray matter literally shrank
so what I learned all this I was that
was I was really that was very
compelling to me the next thing I
learned about meditation that helped me
change my mind is that it doesn't
necessarily involve a lot of the things
that I thought it might for example you
don't have to sit in a funny position
this is one of our cats
Ruby Bianca does not like what I point
out that this cat is basking in the
reflective glow of the Real Housewives
of New Jersey in this in the shot true
story you don't have to sit in if I'm
sorry baby yeah you don't have to sit in
a funny position you don't have to join
a group you don't have to believe in
anything you don't have to wear special
outfits I did talk about the Buddha but
the kind of we should say there are
thousands of kinds of meditation but
when I talk about meditation I'm talking
about mindfulness meditation which is
derived from Buddhism but has been
thoroughly secularized no metaphysical
claims no religious lingo and it is the
kind of meditation that has been studied
most extensively in the labs and so the
thing about mindfulness meditation which
I learned which allowed me really to do
it is how simple it is I'm not gonna
make you do it although I may make you
do it later not gonna make you do it
right now
but just so you know how simple it is
here are the three basic instructions
the first there are three steps four
basic beginning mindfulness meditation
the first is a sick comfortably many
people close their eyes if you don't
like closing your eyes you can kind of
gaze at a neutral spot on the ground the
second is to focus your full attention
on the feeling of your breath coming in
and going out it's a key difference here
you're not thinking about your breath
you're actually just feeling the raw
data of the physical sensations usually
pick one spot where it's most prominent
your belly your chest or your nose and
the third step is the key because as
soon as you try to do this seemingly
easy thing your mind will go into
full-on mutiny you're gonna start
thinking about what's for lunch why did
I say that dumb thing to my professor
where the gerbils run wild why did
Dances with Wolves be Goodfellas for
Best Picture in 1991 bla bla bla and the
whole goal is to notice when you've
become distracted and to start again and
again and again and again and this is a
bicep curl for your brain this is what
shows up on the brain scans and not for
nothing it is also a radical act because
you were short-circuiting a lifetime's
habit of walking around in a fog in this
autopilot of projection and rumination
and you're actually focusing on what's
happening right now so when I learned
everything I just told you I started to
MIT
we have a picture that Bianca took of me
while we're on vacation with some
opportunistic chickens trying to bum
rush me and take my wallet I started
with five to ten minutes a day and I'm
I'm not gonna lie to you it kind of
sucks it's a little bit like oh no it's
a lot like going to the gym if you go to
the gym and you were not panting and
sweating you are cheating and if you sit
to meditate and all of a sudden you all
of your thoughts evaporate and you're in
a bulletproof bubble of bliss
you are either enlightened or you have
died and and so it is a very tricky
thing to do because you have we are we
evolved on the Savannah for threat
detection and finding sources of
pleasure you know we're looking out for
Tigers or looking for food and so we
have a racy mind this is what evolution
has bequeathed us and a racing mind
although it can be racy too and so what
you're doing is trying to sort of hack
evolution and it's tricky but worth it
what is the next slide oh yeah I think
part of the problem at the root of this
pernicious misconception about
meditation this myth that you the only
way to meditate correctly is to clear
your mind I think I think part of what's
produced this is that meditation has
been the victim of the worst marketing
campaign for anything ever and it the
way it's often depicted is like this
people who look like they're floating
off into the cosmos let me just say as
an aside but this is an important aside
and at least in my view another problem
I was happy that the Time magazine put
meditation on its cover they do however
think that it is a mistake to make it
look like the only people meditate our
beautiful blonde women or you know white
people who live on the Upper West Side
of Manhattan and shop at Whole Foods and
I have nothing against those people
because I am one of those people but
meditation was invented 2600 years ago
probably way earlier than that thousands
and thousands of years ago on the Indian
subcontinent this is not for wealthy
white people is for
everybody it is part of our human
birthright to be able to train our minds
in this way but anyway back to the
picture you know this is I think not an
accurate depiction of what the
experience of meditation is like there's
another way to look at it and I think
this is closer to the experience again
getting distracted and starting again is
not a failure getting and distracting is
starting again
is the act of meditation and when you
get distracted that is not that is in
fact a victory I think the important
thing to do is to reframe this as a
victory and it's a victory of real
consequence because when you see how
crazy you are the craziness owns you
less and that is what we're doing in
this practice I forgot what the next
light is okay yeah so I started doing it
as I said five to ten minutes a day and
I started to notice pretty quickly there
were two big benefits although I will
say I first got a sense that it was
working because I would overhear Bianca
at parties telling our friends that I
was less of a [ __ ] so I thought mmm
it's an interesting data point but
internally what the first the two things
I started to show up for me is one it
boosted my ability to focus we live in
an era that has been accurately
described as the info blitz creek where
we're just beset by texts Instagram
stories status updates tweets blah blah
blah all the time and it's very hard to
stay on task
we all have stressful lives especially
if you're a student here yelled and my
job I actually have other people's
voices piped directly into my head and I
need to get it right in front of
millions of people and I found that this
daily exercise of trying to pay
attention to one thing at a time then
getting distracted it's starting again
and again and again really helped me
stay on task and by the way this is
borne out in some of the scientific
research the second benefit is this
rather boring sounding word mindfulness
it is boring sounding word but it is a
game-changing proposition mindfulness is
the ability to see what's going on in
your head
a moment without getting carried away by
it I'm gonna say that again because
mostly what I do in this talk is show
funny pictures and tell embarrassing
stories but this is the take away
mindfulness is the skill of knowing what
is happening in your mind right now
without necessarily taking the bait and
acting on it
we just flesh this out a little bit with
this next slide just just by way of
example say you're standing on line at
Starbucks and somebody cuts you off how
does that go for you I think for most of
us the moment goes like this we have
this uninvited thought of who the hell
is this I'm pissed and then we
automatically reflexively habitually we
inhabit that thought we actually become
pissed there's no buffer between the
stimulus and our blind reflexive
reaction to it with meditation on board
that moment might go a little
differently maybe 10% of the time you
might get cut off and then you notice oh
my chest is buzzing my ears are turning
red I'm having a starburst of self
righteous thoughts I'm getting pissed
but that distance the knowledge this is
clearly seeing that anger is coming up
can help you some percentage of the time
not take the bait and act on it it's a
little bit it's a little bit if you one
way to think about the mind is like a
waterfall the reason why this looks like
[ __ ] is because I drew it you can think
about the mind the way the mind operates
like a waterfall the water is our
non-stop stream of consciousness mostly
me me me thoughts mindfulness is the
area like in the rock face behind the
waterfall to mix my metaphors it's the
space that allows you to kind of step
out of the traffic and to view the
contents of your consciousness with some
non-judgmental remove just a kiss you
think making this up we are classified
as a species as Homo sapiens sapiens the
one who thinks and knows he or she
thinks and yet that second sapiens has
atrophied over time because nobody
bothers to point out to us that we have
this bonus level to use gainer gamers
speak with this bonus level in our minds
that allows us to again to step out of
the traffic into view our habitual
storylines and urges and impulses but
some non judge
remove let me just go back to the
Starbucks example because I suspect some
of you type a Yale folks are thinking
well am I not justified in getting
pissed sometimes absolutely there are
plenty of infuriating things in the
world turn on the news please turn on
the news we need the ratings actually
the the proposition here is not that you
should be rendered into a lifeless
non-judgmental blob the proposition is
that you should learn how to respond
wisely to things instead of reacting
blindly and that is a huge and
game-changing difference and that simple
proposition is why meditation is now
catching on and some really surprising
places
Apple Aetna Procter & Gamble Google
General Mills
by the way General General Mills these
are the people that make Hamburger
Helper so you're not gonna find a more
American company than this and they have
meditation rooms in every building in
their corporate campus in Minnetonka
Minnesota it's also catching on in the
tech world this is an article from Wired
magazine where they refer to meditation
or mindfulness as the tech world's new
caffeine quote-unquote new caffeine I
think it's like deliciously ironic that
the people who are developing the
products and services that are
destroying our ability to focus have
cotton on to this ancient inner
technology to boost their own but I
think there's something to be learned
from that it's also catching on in the
sports world this is a quarterback for
the Seattle Seahawks the Chicago Cubs
meditate the New York Knicks who suck
meditate but don't hold that against
meditation it's also catching on in the
entertainment world as the lead singer
of Weezer Katy Perry Lena Dunham 50 cent
that guy got shot nine times I'm very
happy to hear he's developing some peace
of mind and most intriguingly it's also
catching on in the military to both the
US Marines and the US Army are spending
tens of millions of dollars to look into
whether meditation can make troops who
are more effective in the field make
better decisions in the field less
reactive and more resilient when they
come home in the face of what has become
a scourge of PTSD
okay I'm almost done but before I finish
I'm going to make a prediction and
before I make the prediction I'm gonna
issue a caveat the caveat is that
historically speaking my powers of
prognostication are pretty weak in the
year 2000 I convinced my younger brother
to co-invest with me in the company that
makes the Palm Pilot which didn't do
super well that being said I really
believe that meditation is the next big
public health revolution if we have a
slide that declares that I think of the
not-too-distant future we're gonna think
about mental exercise the way we now
think about physical exercise and these
things can really happen fast in the
1940s if you were going running if you
told somebody I'm going running they
probably would have said who's chasing
you and then what happened the scientist
swooped in they demonstrated the many
physiological and psychological benefits
of exercise and now we all do it and if
we don't do it we feel guilty about it
and that's where I think we're heading
with meditation to be clear I don't
think it's gonna solve all of your
problems that's why I wrote a book and I
called it 10% happier you know I've
learned the hard way that it's not gonna
make you taller or regrow your hair but
it can it can make a huge difference and
I I want to say and I think this is
important for the Yale community in many
ways I really do still believe that the
price of security is insecurity many
ways the same guy was in that picture I
showed you earlier where I was holding a
balloon I think if you can do anything
great in your academic life in your work
life parenting volunteer life whatever
it is there's a certain amount of stress
and plotting and planning but just part
of the deal but we tend to make our
suffering worse than it needs to be and
what meditation with the self-awareness
that that comes from meditation can help
you do is to more successfully and more
consistently draw the line between
useless rumination and what I call
constructive anguish it will not make
you perfect however
if I was dumb enough to give my wife
that mic she would give you the 90%
still a [ __ ] speech and my little
brother the one who I got to invest in
the Palm Pilot has proposed that the
real title for the book should be from
from deeply flawed to merely flawed I
think though at the heart of this is a
really radical and empowering notion
which is that happiness I think we
assume most of us that happiness is
something that happens to us in fact our
ambivalence about the subjects is
reflected in the in the etymology of the
word HAP H ap is the same root of the
word that haphazard and hapless and so
this is the idea that it is luck and
many of us think it's kind of just fully
dependent on the quality of you know
external factors like the quality of our
our marriage the quality of our work
life the quality of our childhood all of
which are super important I don't
downplay them any of them at all but in
fact what the science is showing us is
that happiness is a skill that you can
generate and work on just the way you
would work on your bicep in the gym and
we spend so much time working on our GPA
working on our stock portfolio our cars
our bodies and no time on the one filter
through which we experience everything
so if I can leave you with my little
tagline it's it's that if meditation can
work for a fidgety skeptical newsman it
can work for you thank you very much
appreciate it
thank you for your expert PowerPoint
navigation sir appreciate that we have
time for some questions all right sir
right there I the first thing that I
want to sort of say asked is because a
friend of mine is insisting me that's
why I was on my phone as well she's what
zapping me from India to say that thank
you thank you started I know her pretty
well she's a tense person but she read
your book started meditating and is
really really much better off for it she
recommended it to me in fact and I just
finished reading it yesterday and I was
left with one question like you spoken
towards the end of that book a lot about
how because of equanimity you don't have
to lose your ambition right but at the
same time and I'm saying I'm at the
business school over here and I see it
all the time a lot of times value is
placed on the person who's the quickest
to react quickest and cleverest to react
so if meditation does sort of give you
that sort of peace or the time or the
ability to respond and not react that
wouldn't that sort of hinder you
sometimes from reacting really quickly
which is considered valuable and so how
often or how do you make that decision
of whether you're how quick your
response should be how do you decide
that this is a it's a great question
it's so funny because I was talking to
some Yale students before this and this
was their question as well I mean that
so I think and I've spent a lot of time
thinking about this balance between
peace of mind and being ambitious first
say that I said this earlier but it's
just worth repeating that I I am NOT
against stress I don't see how you can
operate in a high intensity atmosphere
like this or TV news or in the crucible
of parenting which is not yet come your
way I suspect without a certain amount
of stress and I think there's this Kerik
of meditation that it's gonna like that
you're gonna be like that woman on the
front of Time magazine just completely
blissed-out I wish that's how it worked
I wish that you start meditating and all
of a sudden you're just like in a
loincloth on the mountaintop and
Himalayas and wind blowing gently
through your hair isn't just this isn't
how it works and it's not on offer and I
part of it is because we've all these
[ __ ] self-help gurus telling you
that they're you know they're
imperturbable and but that I I think
this is not true I don't believe them
when they say that and I've had the good
fortune to observe many of them up close
and I definitely don't believe it so
that's the first thing to say is I I
don't think this is going to vanquish
all of your stress nor do I think it
should but how much stress makes sense
I'd like to tell the story that I told
some of the students earlier of
meditation retreat I went on and I met
the guy who's now my meditation teacher
was leading his name is Joseph Goldstein
very interesting guy and you know this
because you read it in the book the the
heat was toward the end of the retreat
he said to the group you may find your
minds
drifting now toward what's gonna happen
over after the retreat try not to do
that try not to get into it because you
still on retreat right now and I pop my
hand up it was one of the few moments we
were allowed to talk and ask questions
and I said well wait a minute if I miss
my flight that has real-world
consequences and he said unquestionably
but on the seventeenth time that you're
running through all the horrible
consequences of missing your flight
maybe ask yourself one simple question
is this useful and that is a a just such
an incredible corrective to this belief
that we all have that we need to make
ourselves at least somewhat miserable in
order to succeed but I think it's
important not to make yourself so
miserable that you degrade your ability
to be effective you make yourself
depressed anxious which will hurt your
productivity hurt your focus hurt your
creativity so it's it is I wish I had
and I know all Yale students want this
because it was it
illicitly said to me by your colleagues
by your coast your fellow students they
want some sort of magic formula for
having both of these things that it
isn't like that it's just a meditation
is a tool that you can introduce into
your life so that you are you have a
better shot at achieving some semblance
of balance but to get to the sharp edge
of the question you actually asked me
which is about reacting I'll just be for
my own experience so I spent a lot of
time in live situations on the news one
of the things I do is I host a weekend
Good Morning America and I'm sitting
around on this set with like four or
five other lunatics who can say whatever
they want at any point and it's kind of
my job to like be traffic cop mostly but
I found and I described this in the book
initially that wouldn't everything was
out of my control I would really tense
up and make bad jokes or laugh
uncomfortably or cut people off and when
I was able to drop some of that and be
comfortable really the key is I was I
learned how to pay attention to get out
of my own head to be stopped my own self
referential thinking how am I gonna do
in this moment what am I gonna say
that's gonna be funny how am I gonna you
know impress the bosses but actually
just listening to what people are saying
dropping some my inner monologue then my
responses actually became much sharper
and funnier because I was really right
there and so I would argue that in your
business school classes the amount of
sort of self the voluntary stress that
we put on ourselves to you know achieve
all the time and and which I think some
of which makes sense but you know
probably 50 to 80 percent doesn't make
any sense he's going to degrade your
ability to be right there listening in a
moment and to rely on your natural the
natural intelligence that you've got you
into the school in the first place to
have a response that does make sense in
the moment so that's my experience so I
wouldn't be worried for you as Mike
that's a long way of saying that
sorry just hand the mic to anybody
that's fun meditation for the last 11
years this will be personal meditation
and I have been also hosting lectures at
Yale for last 40 years and meditation
just basically we had our lectures on
March 5th and 6th at Yale so my question
for you is like what I understand
meditation is it is day to day practice
and through this practice you really
understand yourself and learn compassion
and also during that time during that
time I mean you learn your thoughts your
negative emotions to convert into the
positive ones and that is high I mean I
think you succeed or you your thoughts
or those are the negative thoughts when
you change to project you I mean you
become more practical and more become
successful I guess in life or at least
be more happy because you you will know
yourself and that you show to others so
that's what my feeling is and my other
question for you is like you said like
just like PE the physical education
their media legend will come into this
how long will it take but my goal is
like they should start offering such at
least few minutes or and half an hour I
don't know what meditation classes in
schools colleges and all around the
world it's like when do you think that
will happen and then what my wish is
so she asked when when she was saying
that she thinks that meditation should
be taught in schools and I agree I hope
they start teaching it to our
three-year-old ASAP because he's hard to
deal with
I think it's it would be great
there has been some resistance to some
quarters because some people especially
in the Christian community have pointed
out that it has roots in Eastern
spirituality and that that's upsetting
to them but I don't share those concerns
I think that mindfulness meditation
taught correctly is is as I said earlier
secular and so I do think we're heading
toward a world where we're starting to
see it offered in public schools private
schools juvie halls prisons
all sorts of places foster homes all
sorts of places where kids are and I
think there's a really positive trend
and I think it will continue I'm aware
that we only have about ten minutes left
and I was asked I don't know if you guys
are into it but let's do just a couple
minutes of meditation and then ask some
questions on the other side of that you
know really have a choice we're gonna do
like a a 120 second meditation how about
that I'll set it I'll set a okay this is
gonna be two minutes and you'll survive
so the first step as I said before is to
kind of sit with your back straight
which can protect from an unwanted nap
although if you fall asleep not a big
deal second step is really to feel your
breath coming in and going out by the
way if you don't want to close your eyes
you can just kind of gaze at the floor
at an in a soft way in neutral way the
second step is as I said before to
identify the feeling of your breath
coming in and going out and bring your
full attention there usually your chest
or your belly or your nose you don't
have to think about the breath or how
you're doing with the breath just just
feel as I said before the raw data of
the physical sensations and the third
step is as soon as you try to do this
your mind will go nuts what was Casper
the Friendly Ghost before he died blah
blah blah just catch your random
thinking and just begin again and this
moment of noticing you've become
distracted this is so for so many of us
Stryver type-a folks that's when the ego
swoops in and tells you the story that
you're a failed meditator but that's
false that is the moment of success
because seeing how random and self
referential your thinking process is can
help you when you're ambushed by a big
dose of anger or what
where it is later in the day you don't
have to be a boned by it so back to your
breath in out
and when you're ready you can open your
eyes you just went a hundred and twenty
seconds and didn't die so now that we
have a taste of meditation and a sense
of how sort of not whoo it is and down
to earth let's let's do some more
questions and then I'll I'll let you get
back to your day would you talk a bit
about your practice maybe how long you
do it and what times of a day or
whatever okay so this is dicey territory
I so I started with five to ten minutes
a day let me say let me give my shtick
about time for a second then I'll say
something about me one of the biggest
obstacles for people and I wrote about I
wrote a follow-up book after I wrote ten
percent happy I wrote a book called
meditation for fidgety skeptics which is
really about how to actually do the
thing and I perhaps the biggest obstacle
that people have to establishing this as
a habit is finding the time to do it and
so on this score I have good news and
then I have even better news the good
news is I really think five to ten
minutes a day is enough to derive the
advertised benefits of the practice but
if you don't think you have five to ten
minutes a day I think one minute counts
and I think if you shot for one minute
daily ish that would be a great way to
start and frankly if that's all you did
the rest of your life I think you'd be
better off for it would be better for it
in many many ways because again what
we're trying to do here is to engineer a
collision between you and the [ __ ] in
your head and why is that important
because when you see the man behind the
curtain for who he or she really is then
you start to not be able to not be owned
by it so much you know you you you're
able to resist the shitty suggestions of
oh yeah you should eat the xviii Oreo or
say the thing that's gonna ruin the next
48 hours of your marriage and that can
happen in a minute
Oh so how much do I do I started with
five ten minutes a day and then after
about a year I switched to 30 minutes a
day and then a couple of years ago and
again this is me speaking and this is
not something anybody else has to do but
I started you know I now have a company
that teaches people how to meditate
through an app and I travel around the
country in the world speaking about
meditation and I'm writing more books
about it and I personally have a deep
deep interest in the practice so I went
to 2 hours a day which is for many
people kind of gasp inducing but it's
actually less impressive than it might
sound because my way of the rule I have
for myself is I can do meditation
whenever I want wherever I want for
whatever increments I want so my
schedule is crazy I as I've described a
ganker a couple of shows on ABC News one
is a early morning show on the weekend
the other is a late night show during
the week I travel a lot I have a
business and we have a child and so I
just kind of fit it in where I can I did
some on the train coming up here I'll do
some more on the car going home I have
to be at the office tonight I'll get
some in there and so my goal that they
have every day is just to get to 2 hours
and I'll tell you my rationale partly is
that if you can be 10 percent happier
and I honestly believe you can and even
though it's kind of a joke but what's
the ceiling you know if these skills the
things that we want most in our lives
peace of mind happiness generosity
compassion if these things are they're
not factory settings that can't be
tinkered with their actual skills if you
can train all of these why not really go
for it coming right here
thanks for coming thanks for your you're
talking sherry but you've shared so far
I have a question about sort of the
linkage between mindfulness and
happiness if we sort of just flesh that
out more directly because I I could
imagine being much more mindful and sort
of you know whipping your brain into
shape and knowing when you're sort of
having these ruminations and your
thoughts are veering off from where you
you know might want to focus but still
that like I don't understand like the
direct link between how that in and of
itself would make you happier if you
still occupy a station in life where
like you're sort of fundamentally
unhappy knowing that you yeah I think I
think it's such it's such an excellent
question there was a study also done at
Harvard sorry with a ping today I had
the study participants had an app on
their phone and kind of brilliant as a
study design and they study authors
would ping people throughout the day at
random times and asked them what are you
doing right now
how closely you're paying attention and
how happy are you know they found was
the conclusion of the study is they want
and this was actually the title of the
study a wandering mind is an unhappy
mind then when people are paying
attention to what they're doing that is
when they're at their most happy and it
is kind of come it does kind of come
down to a definition of happiness so I
think we often in this culture conflate
happiness with excitement excitement is
like gratifying an urge winning the
lottery having that first drag of a
cigarette whatever that isn't
necessarily happiness which is more
about just deeper than that it's a
deeper sort of peaceful satisfaction
that often comes from connection really
can only come from connecting to
whatever is happening right now but that
when we're wondering our minds are
wandering
tends to be really negative does it mean
when you're mindful and awake and aware
that all of the problems in the world
will evaporate all the in equities and
iniquities of the world will go away no
of course not but on an individual level
your best shot at feeling this kind of
satisfaction comes from inhabiting where
you are right now as opposed to spinning
off into worries about the future and
regrets and anger about the past again
that's not to say that that stuff is
never warranted but we live there when
in fact you know your body's always
right here yeah that's a excellent
question and you put your finger on the
fact that you know there are many of us
have difficult lives and just waking up
you know through this process of
meditation isn't going to solve all
those problems but I would argue that's
the space from which solutions are met
most available we're out of time thank
you very much really appreciate it
[Applause]
I'm Andrew siphon from the office of the
secretary and vice president for student
life and on behalf of secretary Kim Goff
Cruz I'd like to thank dan dan Harris
for coming to New Haven this afternoon
for sharing his story and his learning
dan has a website and podcast as you can
see there please check it out
learn more students please check out
Yale well which is the initiative which
sponsored this event its website brings
together resources from across the
university that concentrate on happiness
and well-being on them living a full
life as a student and as a person also
check out being well which is
particularly useful if you're a Yale
staff or faculty member it's the kind of
companion initiative on your behalf I'd
like to thank Emma so Paula who
introduced dan and brought him really to
Yale today and also am Heather Calabrese
who put together this event with her
team and a final thank you to you and
for making out and a busy April and
please join me once again in thanking
Dan Harris for being here
[Applause]
[Music]